Speaker 1: You know, something that the American
right wing does a lot.
They project and I don't mean they project
movies onto the side of a building.
I'm not talking about a literal projector
here.
What I mean is they accuse the left of doing
that, which they themselves actually do.
And there are so many different areas in which
we could talk about this.
But one of those areas recently has really
scaled up a lot to include claims that the
Left is brainwashing children into their own
dogmas, often through critical race theory
or through college, which many believe is
liberal indoctrination or in other ways they're
going after the kids.
It turns out that it's actually the right
that is doing this, and a viewer sent me a
link to some toe curling Trump propaganda
aimed at kids with former Arkansas Republican
Governor Mike Huckabee involved as well.
You have to see this because this is them
doing what they accuse the left of doing.
This is something called.
The kid's guide to President Trump.
And if you go to the website, which I mean,
I guess we'll link to it, I don't know, it's
not like we're not promoting it, but you should
be able to look at this for yourselves.
There's a picture of Mike Huckabee, and it's
promoted as help your kids learn the truth
about President Trump and celebrate America
with this free patriotic gift bundle.
Mike Huckabee, co-founder of the Kids Guide
and one of the products, is called The Kid's
Guide to Donald Trump.
But as drawings of Trump swearing in his own,
swearing his oath of office with his hand
on a Bible being held by Abraham Lincoln.
If you want to look at some propaganda and
here's everything you get with this bundle,
you get the kids guide to President Trump.
You get to learn our learn our histories great
again.
Restoring faith in America.
Streaming VIDEO And it's like a run on sentence.
It's just crazy.
And then you also get the Everbright Kids
magazine, which is more right wing trash bundled
for children.
This free gift bundle will look at the language.
Help your kids learn all about Trump's greatest
accomplishments during his first term first
term.
I like that.
Give your kids a sneak peek inside the Trump
presidency and look at Look at the description
here, and I'll zoom in on it for you.
The mainstream media has been no friend to
President Trump.
They market this as like history material.
The mainstream media has been no friend to
President Trump, and they'll never admit that
he did a great job leading our country and
making the changes America needs.
Give us a list of those changes.
But as future voters, our children and grandchildren
deserve to understand the truth about Trump
and what made him a great president.
This is what they say the left is doing.
You could not get something more cartoonishly
insane than this.
That's why we're giving away our free patriotic
kids bundle to help your kids and grandkids
learn the truth about Trump and his accomplishments.
This fun bundle includes the things I told
you about.
You get them both for just a dollar, shipping
and processing each.
The kid's guide to President Trump is unbiased
and will help your kids learn everything there
is to know.
From his election in 2016 and his greatest
accomplishments as an added bonus, we're giving
you unlimited access to the Great Again Restoring
Faith in America.
VIDEO and Digital Work Workbook.
What's more, the special issue of Everbright
Kids magazine will help your kids celebrate
America and enjoy oodles, just oodles and
oodles of great content and activities to
keep them entertained for hours.
Oh, and by the way, it's sort of one of these
subscription drifts, because look at this
as part of the special offer, your kids can
look forward to a new kids guide covering
an important topic for kids once a month,
including a streaming video lesson and workbook,
all for just $20 in 90 cents.
Plus, we'll send your kids a new issue of
Everbright Kids magazine each month for only
$5 and 75 cents.
Oh God, it's a financial grift as much as
it is a political grade.
It's this is the indoctrination.
This is the propaganda they say, you know,
you send your kids to college, they're going
to get indoctrinated.
You send your kids to school.
There might be teachers teaching critical
race theory or there might be teachers.
Are you teaching other stuff?
But with the framework of critical race theory,
this is the propaganda guys.
This is the propaganda the kids guide for
patriotic kids with the truth about President
Donald Trump.
Toe curling, propaganda, toe curling propaganda.
Absolutely horrible stuff.